please welcome scarlett johansson
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
make that seat perfect for you hello oh
my god
it's been a long time i know
i know
we've been friends for so long and
you've known me in so many iterations of
my life
i mean like heartbreak like
too wasted at a bar you know
dancing around like fools and playing
games we spent christmas together that
time we spent christmas in austin texas
and i remember your friend's mom made
every single piece of the meal was a
casserole
i have never had there were nine
casseroles it was unbelievable like
green bean casserole a sweet potato
casserole like the turkey was a
casserole it was crazy remember that
yeah cause i wasn't cooking so i was
like i'll take anything you got
and then we did he's just not that into
you and we played really good
girlfriends and it just like flowed and
we started hanging out yeah which is why
it means so much to like you know have
you here because we've
we've known each other you know we
weren't moms then so that scene we
weren't mom's then but i have to i have
to remind you remember that was in a sea
they should we shot that i think it was
a cvs or like a rite aid or something
that they had closed yes and they said
you know you guys are feel free to like
go shopping while you're in this rated
and i think you and i bought it because
i was like oh my god i love a rating or
whatever and you were like this is my
dream to spend all day in a pharmacy and
so we just went up and down the aisles
like doing our shopping um that was so
much fun that scene um i had worked with
mark and abby the writers on expressing
uh my character's point of view about
getting rejected in several portals and
back then there weren't half as many
portals as there are now yes there's a
lot of ways to be rejected
so i was wondering like
do you have any dating advice for me
for you yes what do you need dating
advice for your you're you because i
kind of just want to hear your take on
dating advice
i'm so happy being single i don't feel
desperate i've got kids so my cup run is
over i have the most incredible friends
the most amazing are you dating
i try but i
am so obsessed with the collective
conscious of how difficult it can be how
do you meet people well that's big a big
part of the problem i mean
i just i don't know i can't imagine
what dating would be like with kids well
that's not true i had my daughter when i
met colin but
you know we met at snl and it was like
i'd known him
for
a very very long time through my first
year hosting was his first year
writing so that was eons ago and um
you also have hosted
your five timer right six me too six oh
yeah
[Applause]
there's like not so great on the show
i say chandeliers every single day or
all my life
i mean i quote your snl characters on a
daily basis so it's so funny because
colin wrote a lot of those characters
and like all those pieces and stuff and
it's just it's such a funny thing like
looking back on it now but you know we
it was just the timing was good like
when we met the timing was right it's so
you knew him
did you ever find him attractive or was
it like
like one other time all of a sudden it
looked different um i i mean you know
he's he's a very
i think a very cute guy but i
you know
the other times that i was there i was i
was you know in a relationship and i was
not like you know like oh he's cute but
you know right
and um this time the time it was the
timing was right it was like he yeah he
i think he
looked differently to me because i was
available like it was just
the timing has to be right i think like
i've definitely been with in
relationships where the timing was
not right and i also kind of think you
have to recognize one thing when it's
not
obvious if you know it's not the right
person it's not the right person but
sometimes it's a good person but the
timing is off and
it's important to be open to that too
like you know what i mean
[Music]